okay question for you I I get this every
single time I do like you say like a
panel of convention alright I get the
question is how do you deal with hey cuz
I'm of the philosophy you never deal
with it
you just come to accept it yeah you just
learn together get over it
that you remember how you you know like
that's that's like a very I'm like I
feel very passionate about this because
I feel like there's no right answer for
this and I feel like the right answer is
that we just basically gonna check
ourselves online and just don't be a
[ __ ] dick right because it's it's
unfortunate right because I get this I
get asked the question a lot as well and
every crate I've talked to there's
there's no solution
well you just get used to it right you
just you just got to ignore it right and
to me that's [ __ ] insane because I
thought what a solution that's a coping
mechanism yeah you know what I mean but
that's the only thing we can do when we
when we have to deal with hate yeah I'm
sure I'm sure she won't mind if I share
this but Jessica Nigri
yeah a really good friend of mine I
asked Affleck's I asked this question to
her because you know when she blow up
she was getting noticed by everybody
when you blow up in that sense you also
gain a lot of haters on fire yes how it
works right and so I remember I think a
kiosk to the question of how do you how
did you get through that yeah we all saw
as a third person just how brutal her
hate yeah yeah yeah and so Aki asked her
she was like so how did you how do you
like deal with it yeah and I think
Jessica said it in the most perfect way
and she just said it's not that you deal
with you do end up dealing with it yeah
they're never stops hurting no no it
didn't and and I think that just
perfectly sums it up you learn to deal
with it but it never stops hurting every
time if you see that one hate comment
that's just it just hits you in that the
worst spot possible yeah like you'll
learn to deal with it because you've
seen so many examples like no matter how
immune you are there's always that one
comment every so often that comes up
they're just you're just like yeah I
just ruined that just rude
and I thought I was above this but
you're never above it oh you know I'm
I'm a person who I'd say I'm I'm not
self-conscious about many things oh yeah
on average for people I speak to there's
maybe like one or two things I'm
self-conscious about yeah and it's just
like do they can say whatever they want
but if they hit that one thing that I
was warned about that one day yeah that
[ __ ] hurt yeah because I think one story
that's I've experienced on like a
secondhand experience and I'm sure
Sydney's fine with me telling this story
is that she was she became a meme okay
she this was this was back when cringe
culture was like at its prime yeah so
she made like she made a video when she
was a kid that was like it was like it
was kind of like a parody of like yonder
raised and just like the anime we've
kind of girl but it was to the point
when you know people couldn't tell it
was satire
yeah they don't know the place that she
wasn't really a youtuber back then she
was just a girl on the Internet
yeah years later leafy featured it in a
video yeah and that just [ __ ] blew up
why she became she became a meme and I
like I was on YouTube at this point so I
know like the right the right and wrong
things that you can do online but even
seeing it from a secondhand perspective
it was like it was hard right because
she'd wake up and she would just get
death death threats every single day
like she I had to just delete Twitter
delete facebook because it got to the
point when people from her school were
messaging her about it that's how
widespread it wasn't like we've I've
never talked about this publicly but it
was [ __ ] hard right cuz like I love
Sydney and like I did not know the right
way way to deal with it so what I what I
did was I was like okay this is the only
way I could like I could make it a bit
better so I wrote like a parody video
for her which is if if you've seen
Sydney's video called like how-to beats
and the rails or something along those
lines where she basically satirizes it
that was like that was that was my way
of trying to help her get out of it
because you know on the internet if you
say something is bad or if you say
you're hurting that's only gonna make it
10 times worse so yeah so I I try to
deal with it by just trying to make a
joke out of it and - and
stance it works but to this day like
Sydney still like sometimes she gets
notifications on her Facebook or Twitter
and it's just it's it affects her it
never went away because we went through
like a whole year period where she was
just afraid of social media because she
was afraid of opening up a message and
then someone new was like mocking Hills
someone she knew personally was mocking
her and it's like this is what I like
feel really strongly about this because
I don't feel like there's a right way
you can deal with it the only way we can
deal with it is just to make sure that
we as a community don't act shitty
online and just and just know that there
is a person behind the avatar and we can
it's it's so easy to forget a lot of the
times even for us you see a number if we
see our view counts and we just like
that's that's just a number but like
behind behind every number behind every
avatar there is someone there
and especially with what's been going
online nowadays you know me and some of
the stuff that's been happening on
Twitter and YouTube recently we I think
it's super super important that we as a
community
tridem just act better yeah yeah yeah
because because there's no there's no
way to regulate this so the only the
only way the only way I can think of is
just to promote just acting better and
being better online since when did it
become so hard for people on the
internet to just act like a normal
[ __ ] human being it's it's weird
because the mentality people have is
just strange like my old housemate used
to do like kpop dance videos I'm like
you know there maybe be like I don't
know like 2030 comments on those videos
yeah and I remember there was one time
when someone said that she looked like
chubby in one of the dances right and
then she replied being like you know
what the [ __ ] yeah and then this person
replied saying oh I never thought you'd
see it yeah yeah that's that's the thing
right that's the that's the weird
mentality that I think some people have
where they think oh they're never gonna
see this like no we'll see it yeah every
youtuber said that time and time again
we see it we see it but then a part of
me is like is that like a bad thing to
say that we're gonna see it because is
that gonna make them comment more I just
feel like this is a salute this is a
problem that's never gonna have a
solution none except that just you know
maybe if we keep repeating the message
of you know
I'm not gonna be I'm not gonna get mega
upset about anything I might get a
little Balder but I'm gonna be fine but
yeah you know with some of the
unfortunate stuff that has happened
recently with you know a lot of online
personalities and you know some taken
there in life yeah that's really it's
pretty terrifying that to think that
maybe some of my friends might not be
able to handle that yeah I'd like and
that's why you know like I think I'm
sure we can all agree that we all very
strongly advocate for mental health
among youtubers and there's a reason why
so many youtubers do have mental health
issues is because of stuff like this
because we were never like we like us
just as human beings you know we we
evolution never taught us how to deal
with 50 million people sending your
clown emotes you just have to learn
through trial and error and
unfortunately a lot of the times some
people are just not psychologically
equipped to handle a certain amount of
hate or yeah you know and yeah I mean
you know do you ever find that we like
did you ever like do YouTube or like
watch YouTube videos to like escape real
life yeah but but well like now
sometimes you feel like you have to
switch off to it turn switch off YouTube
and escape that in real life like it's
it's weird cuz it's so easy just it like
going back to Satoshi Kon right it's it
is totally like being sucked into
another world oh yeah
it is a separate world where you exist
in that world and the best way I can
describe getting a lot of hate is there
just I don't know why but it just feels
suffocating oh you know what I mean you
could be sitting in your living room no
one's there but you could just feel like
suffocated just like with all these
comments being like thrown onto you it's
it's really hard and there's no right
way to deal with it as a as a person yes
because this is an interesting that we
could you know upload a video and it get
200 dislikes and we think ultimately 200
people yeah but if you think about in
real life times like walking into a
fully packed cinema and all those people
just immediately turning to you and
saying [ __ ] you that's what it feels
like that's what hundred dislikes it
looks like
yeah and it's so weird how so many
youtubers are just kind of know